terrible ch il te plait alors jean yanne
voulu me faire de la radio j'ai voulu
faire de la télé vous avez voulu
réaliser des films j'ai voulu faire des
affaires une société de tournage de
films français aux états unis et films
américains en france vous avez voulu
faire de la décoration d'hôtel mais si
vous aviez choisi d'être que acteurs
pensait pas qu'aujourd'hui vous seriez
un des premiers acteurs du monde pas
seulement un acteur parce que c'est pas
moi qui ai choisi d'être acteur c'est
pas moi c'était pas mon truc moi je suis
je voulais faire partie du spectacle et
surtout je voulais écrire les choses
cote quand des femmes demande on me dit
mais qu'est ce que vous regrettez le
plus joli je regrette simplement que
pendant des années on mais on ne met pas
demandé les clefs dialogue
j'étais persuadé que je serai un bon
dialogue ne rien gâcher le gars vous
hier ne le disaient les études vrai
qu'on dirait mais les gens voulaient pas
mais je dis ça sans aigreur puisque j'ai
fait une autre chose plus lucratives
ouais mais pour moi acteurs c'est pas le
truc évidemment qui me passionne le plus
faire et si c'était à refaire pour
travailler la même chose et je t'ai je
vais refaire je referais la même chose
dans les grandes lignes c'est à dire que
je met par exemple je ferai beaucoup
plus de choses dans la décoration ou
beaucoup plus chaude dans urban ah oui
beaucoup de boue plus de choses dans les
choses comme ça
pas trop dans la musique c'est bien
français mais j'aurais adoré travailler
avec avec des urbanistes j'aurais aimé
partie du projet brasilia tout ce
facteur qua non pas tous aux facteurs
mais on est toujours acteur de quelque
chose dans une société qui nous entoure
on a les mains dorian